[Applause]
but we're thinking about we're thinking
about Florida right now no we are there
they are they are looking at a category
five liberal hoax is about dead
know this this is serious if you are
watching me in Florida
stop get the [ __ ] out right now no
seriously this is rare you know this is
really serious stuff there and not just
that hurricane there are three
hurricanes lined up irma in Florida Jose
in the Caribbean and Katya coming to
Mexico I'm just saying if you're a coke
smuggler take the weekend off this is
this is not a good time to be out and
and these are like they said this arm is
the most serious storm ever like I'm
seeing colors on the hurricane maps I've
never seen before here's a little guide
if you see yellow like Trump's hair take
extra care if you see orange like his
face shelter-in-place and red like his
ties to Russia just evacuate down
now it's about to hit Florida this storm
but Trump says not to worry we are
completely prepared the National Guard
is in place FEMA is well supplied
Melania has her stilettos arm
I called them flood me pumps
get the flood meat 1 but you know the
the people in Florida can take solace in
the fact that they will soon get a visit
from Donald Trump the comforter in chief
they're calling it because you know what
I think of comfort and empathy and warm
fuzzy feelings nobody comes to mind like
Donald Trump he's he's a Snuggie in
human form this guy did you see him in
Houston he brought the first lady I've
never seen a president do that he
brought a date to a flood honey and of
course his fans loved it they thought he
was very brave to face his greatest
nemesis of the last 30 years wind
[Applause]
I tell you who did not look too good
there in Houston was mr. pastor I should
say Joel Osteen you know this guy he
wouldn't he's got a megachurch he
wouldn't let people shelter in his
church during a storm mr. Christian
and this Czech boy talk about mega it
seats 17,000 people and on Sunday he
fills it up three times he preaches to
52,000 people the Catholics are like
while we're molesting the wrong people
[Applause]
oh speaking of molesting the wrong
people
this week with North Korea exploding a
hydrogen bomb and these weather
catastrophes all over the country who
does Trump go after the dreamers do you
saw this that he threatened to end the
program we refer to as daca people don't
know what that stands for it's deferred
action for childhood arrivals says the
same thing on my condoms
[Applause]
I pointed like I'm wearing one now
I don't trust you people I'm wearing a
condom no Daka is the the program that
President Obama started to allow the
children of undocumented immigrants soon
have never known any of the country and
to stay here they spent their entire
lives in this country there they're so
Americanized their car horns place at
Taylor Swift
it's the condom it's no but they're
leading very productive lives more than
most people but the over 90 percent are
employed a lot of them are in the
military they're very well educated they
all they almost all believe in climate
change yeah this is so interesting
climate change the deniers all have
beach houses in the way you know if this
is did you read this all in the way of
this storm
Trump Rush Limbaugh and Coulter the Koch
brothers all have houses that are gonna
be wiped out probably I'm not gloating
it's just an inconvenient truth I'm not
trying to now Trump has a 28 million
dollar compound on the island of st.
Martin's and it looks like it's gonna
get tabouli wiped out today he said door
and that's where I keep my tax returns
but you know even though everything that
scientists said was going to happen that
the waters were gonna get warmer and
this gonna soup up the storms and that
erm is the worst storm ever and harvey
was a 502 one shot and they've had three
of the three years in a row with five
hundred to one shots the right-wingers
are still now we can't blame climate
change yes I agree my theory is has
something to do with Hillary's emails
[Applause]
[Music]
rush limbaugh has been telling his
listeners all week that emma is a
liberal hoaxster promote client their
climate change agenda but that he had to
evacuate his house which for rush has
got to be a tough pill to swallow but if
anybody knows about swallowing pills